how are you this morning Pat damn I'm a
little heartbroken because I can't
believe that girl left Fitz harmony man
you heard about that no I did none this
harmony lost one of their members
you know fifth harmony is death no maybe
that's why it didn't affect me big win
in Minnesota yesterday cold as hell and
the holidays are right around the corner
everything's good over here in kool-aid
if we can make the playoffs which is a
very slim chance but if we can do it
life would be fantastic how are you dad
how's the whole gang over there morale
is high we have a we have our Christmas
our office Christmas party coming up I
got him sony 4k tvs already i feel like
a connor back with his offensive line
does anybody just like Andrew Luck get
you anything for Christmas no no no
Andrew doesn't give me anything Adam
Vinatieri got me a very expensive bag
last year which is very nice Adam so
didn't tear you know I'm the man to kind
of hold his ball as he takes you Jeremy
in the but that's about it we do a
little little Christmas exchange in the
special teams room but that's we don't
have quarterback money so the gifts are
although Adam Vinatieri part of the
richest guy on earth the gifts are
fantastic but Adam normally takes care
of a year in and year out if you had to
kick outside yesterday in Minnesota how
absurd so you hear about Minnesota being
cold you know you're always like it's in
rap songs cold as Minnesota stuff like
that but yesterday when we got out of
the hotel to walk to our bus I
accidentally had my jacket open and that
cold air really just went right inside
of me stole my soul that's the coldest
I've ever felt in my entire I've been in
some cold situation go through a lake
ice fishing as a child wasn't as cold is
what happened yesterday Minnesota I
think I think if I have to point outside
yesterday it was negative 20 that was
just a regular temperature I have no
idea what the windchill was and I have
no idea how they judge negative 20 I
don't know what
device tells a map but it was the
coldest I've ever felt it's just a
different level and I probably would
have quit yesterday if I had to kick a
ball out there I don't know what would
happen I mean I'm just not tough enough
for that mentally or physically then but
you had three punts yesterday against
Minnesota what do you do the rest of the
time
well I kick off that's right yeah that's
yeah Stadium announcers don't normally
know Adam Vinatieri here to kick off
sweet fun couple kickoff held for Adam
you know that's a pretty good little day
but I don't do nearly enough to earn the
salary that I make I understand that but
if you do other punters look like you'll
go well yeah but he plays indoors or you
know he plays in Tampa you know so do
you guys look at that when it comes to
who's the best puncher in the league and
factor that in I think there's some
judgment that happens from a lot of
people and I would judge too but the
biggest difference between punters and
everything is their coverage teams you
know some teams are built to be fast
some teams are built to be a little bit
bigger teams and I think you can just
tell if a guy's good or not
indoor/outdoor but I think there's
definitely some judgment I know if I was
playing in Kansas City or Cleveland like
the Colquitt brothers or if I was
outside I would judge the dome punters
and kickers I would most certainly do it
I think it's just it's in my heart I
think I would judge them but I'm very
lucky to be in the situation I'm in
although in Lucas Oil Stadium which is
our stadium here opens the roof and the
window it's just it's a we have a
retractable roof it's like a convertible
you know we take the roof off when the
windows down anytime we want and when
they open that up it becomes a wind
tunnel but that Vikings dome is
definitely something that's needed
because if we had to go outside
yesterday I really I would cry
embarrassing moment for everybody
alright I want your honest reaction the
first time you saw John Ryan with the
fake punt with the Seahawks when he took
off and started running well I was like
wow he's out you know he's a very pale
man in wearing that highlighter outfit
I thought he looked good you know I
thought that teller soon lived well for
a skin complexion he was running he was
striding he was galloping he's a man
who's in good shape but he was trying to
form a wide receiver he was tucking the
ball too tight and I said this on social
media when you're a punter and you don't
carry the ball off and you're gonna go
street football carry that thing like a
loaf of bread and just let it keep
moving because your shoulder pads are
gonna get in the way of a good time
and that's what happened for John I
think the ball scraped off the shoulder
pad kind of got loose kind of and then
he got killed he died right there on the
field but I'm happy got out there and
made a play I like to see the big fella
stride out a little bit but I think you
just need to slide enjoy the moment and
I think you'll learn that for next time
but John line is a great Bunter and a
great athlete so I'm happy got loose on
national TV is Marquette King trying to
be the showman here I mean is he setting
a new standard for punchers here I think
you national people don't really pay
attention to much Marquette really came
in and kind of stole the show because
he's an incredibly talented putter and
he's got some some swag you know I think
I think it's safe to say he has some
swag at Marquette and I are good friends
we've known each other for a long time
so I was real excited to see him getting
some love there but a lot of you
national people don't make those here
are you doing I've seen you after a punt
I've seen you do your shimmy whatever
you know yeah thank you then I
appreciate that and that's why you're at
the top of the class Marquette you're
the best white dancing punter in the
league you know I'll take that because
there's 31 of us you know so there's 31
white guys one black guy and I'll tell
you what Marquette is gonna be the best
punter in the game here in a few years
he's incredibly talented he's incredibly
gifted and I think the NFL is lucky to
have him and I'm being serious when I
say that could you make the Hall of Fame
no you have no chance I don't think so I
think Ray Guy is such a big name and
funning because he changed the way
people viewed punters because he started
turning the
over in big balls and stuff like that he
was really the first guy to kind of kind
of set the tone on what a punter can be
but right now we have 32 punters in our
league that are just really 12 let's not
say 13 there's probably like 15 16
really good guys in the NFL right now
and to make it me I'm making the Hall of
Fame you got to do special stuff I mean
Bennett Aires don't and he's got
something legendary KAK's he's 21 years
into the league he's still one of the
top two guys top three guys in the game
so he's gonna make it but gonna be put
in situations and really come through if
you're a specialist and obviously Adams
done that Ray guy changed the game for
me to make it it's gonna be real tough
for any punter to make it from now on
gonna be real tough he is a completed
50% of his passes and he averages 18
yards per carry he's Pat McAfee of the
Colts next game by the way will be
against Marquette King and the Raiders
in Oakland but this is a showdown I
don't care about luck versus Carr I mean
I care about you versus King this is
gonna be great a kickoff yes a punt off
yeah yeah that's what's gonna bring the
ratings and I think Andrew Luck
understands that I think Jerry medical
wheeled Mac
py Hilton there's a lot of incredible
football players out there but this is
King and McAfee stepping out there on
Christmas Eve Saturday night in the
black hole where else would you rather
be for the holidays really right there
and Oakland and it's gonna be a showdown
a lot of big balls can I you know really
close my eyes and just kick the hell out
of those things and Marquette King and I
are gonna have a little embrace before
and afterwards but during it's show time
and we're excited for it I think that's
gonna be a big game though yes for us we
have to win obviously and Oakland I mean
this is Christmas Eve game on national
TV for them this is gonna be this is
gonna be awesome I'm just real excited
to get out there I hope the weather's a
lot warmer than it was in Minnesota but
it will be it will be does whether
deflate footballs well said well said a
lot of things I think so here's here's a
real answer so for me I want when you're
kicking or punting you want the ball as
hard as possible so a deflation of the
bow
actually hurt you because you can't get
enough pop on the ball when it is colder
outside the exterior of the ball is
still as hard as a regular Bowl but the
inside loses some air so you kind of got
like an ice cream cone with a chocolate
filling you know there's no like you
know the chocolate crust on the outside
of an ice cream cone oh yeah yeah yeah
so that's kind of what a ball feels like
so the cold weather does affect the ball
whenever it comes to kicking it because
it's soft running inside harder on the
outside so it doesn't go as far so that
is a factual statement it does deflate
the ball well I don't know the science
behind it Dan you know and I probably
will get quoted in some lawsuit as soon
as I would assume that the cold air does
deflate the ball a little bit he's a
male but I was a part of that game damn
I was a part of that game and boy there
is a lot of talk and science behind it
and I'm Way too dumb he involved all
that all I know is when the ball gets
cold doesn't travel as far and when the
ball is hot it goes to the moon so I'm
all about a nice hot air and kicking the
hell out of a football did you think
that those balls were under-inflated
when you played the Patriots I don't
touch Tom Brady's balls so I'm nowhere
near those boss K ball is a completely
different operation but that's an egg
policy on your part right okay boss know
that you don't touch Brady's balls I
mean I would that guy really good at
everything trying to get everything you
possibly could if I could touch the
balls maybe little greatness would kind
of spew over through osmosis hmm but the
cables the QB balls are just a complete
different operation that goes back to
Mitch Berger and Brett Favre almost
having a throwdown so I had no idea I
didn't feel his balls at all I didn't
feel the Patriots balls I didn't feel
our quarterback balls I kind of got my
own thing going with the other team's
kickers and punters and so I have no
idea I couldn't feel but I know that the
people in our sideline from our
equipment managers to everybody else are
really really good people and they
wouldn't attempt to screw anybody over
without for no reason they're really
really good people
Pat McAfee the Colts
punter releasing a documentary-style
stand-up comedy DVD at the beginning of
the new year coming up next will be the
Raiders on Christmas Eve Pat be safe in
Oakland ok and thanks for joining us
hey you know what thanks for having me
happy Holidays to all of you Fritzi this
the first time Fritz didn't even call
and asked me to come on the show or text
and ask me a show he just texted me and
told me I'm coming on and I want to let
you know that relationship that we've
done to that level I'm real excited
about it this is a big day this is our
Christmas miracle coming true so I'm
excited to be here happy new years happy
holidays all of you guys in face write
mail the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]